hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain the mystery thriller film called
julia's eyes
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie starts when we see a blind
woman named sarah talking to an
invisible presence
the presence has been tormenting her for
days it plays songs and follows her
around the house
sarah cannot take more of this so she
goes to the basement to hang herself
just then she feels the presence near
her she changes her mind
but before she can remove the news
someone kicks the tool away
a person from a corner clicks a picture
of her hanging to death
a set of hospital tools lies on a table
nearby
sarah's twin sister julia lives miles
away from her
as sarah hangs to death julia collapses
she senses something wrong
and decides to visit sarah julia and her
husband
isaac come looking for sarah and find
her dead in the basement
sarah and julia both have the same kind
of disease that made their vision
progressively worse
eventually making them blind but sarah's
vision had gotten bad before julius
at home the police officer suggests
declaring it a case of suicide
he suspects sarah got depressed with her
blindness so she committed suicide
however julia insists it is not as sarah
was waiting for a donor to get her
vision back
she believes this is not a case of
suicide but that of murder
he then informs her of a blind lady
named soledad who sarah used to talk to
julia visits soledad and gets to know
about a place named bauman center
a place for handicapped people she tells
her that sarah had made new friends
there
julia visits the place when she goes
there she hears a group of blind women
gossiping about sarah
sarah had a boyfriend who she went with
to a hotel in bella vista
the women noticed julia's presence and
confront her
when she introduces herself they ask who
the man she came with is
julia is surprised because she had come
alone but the women sent someone
standing right behind her
julia sees someone walk out she chases
the person
and reaches a small dark room the person
is right in front of her
but she cannot see him due to the
darkness he flashes his camera which
distracts julia
and he escapes her eyesight goes weak
isaac wants her to go back home because
any more stress will cause julia to lose
her vision
but she convinces him to go to bella
vista for a holiday
in reality she wants to find out sarah's
boyfriend whom the blind women had been
talking about
as they arrive in bella vista she
chooses the hotel in which sarah stayed
with her boyfriend
in the hotel she cannot find any record
of sarah's boyfriend
later at lunch a waitress tells her that
her twin sarah
already had her eye operation so she is
confused as to why sarah committed
suicide as she already had the operation
then isaac reveals that sarah's doctor
told him that her eye operation was not
successful
according to him this is the reason
sarah committed suicide
as julia is about to leave the hotel a
janitor named crespilo says that he
found something in sarah's hotel room
he guides her to sarah's room and gives
her a key that belonged to sarah
crespilo also tells her to be careful of
the man in the dark
just then julia senses someone behind
her the person runs away before she can
catch him
julia and isaac then go to get
surveillance camera footage to identify
the person sarah was with
isaac goes in to get the footage but
never comes back
when julia goes into check isaac is not
there all the footages are gone to
she reports to the police about isaac's
disappearance and tells them about the
invisible man
just then we see crest below bathing in
a tub
someone cuts off the light bulb over him
it electrocutes him to death
the police and julia come looking for
crespulo and find him dead
julia is now sure that the invisible man
has killed crespulo and kidnapped her
husband
worry about isaac she gets a seizure
that further weakens her eyesight
she goes to see her doctor who tells her
that she has less than a month before
she goes fully blind
he arranges and i transplant surgery for
her
later that day she goes back to
soledad's house soledad had a husband
and a son named angel
her husband left her and angel had
looked after her for 10 years before
suddenly leaving one day
shortly the police find isaac's last
location to be a motel
they also find his wedding ring in the
room he stayed in
as the inspector and julia are in the
motel talking
another officer comes saying that
someone is at julia's home
the two of them return back inspector
goes to check into a room
when julia hears a noise from the
basement she goes down to check
but because of her eyesight and the
room's darkness she doesn't see anything
she feels around the room and suddenly
touches a man
scared she starts to yell for help the
inspector comes down
and tries to calm her suddenly the
lights come back
isaac's body hangs from the ceiling he
has committed suicide
but even when the lights are on julia
can't see she has gone fully blind
the following day at the hospital the
inspector tells julia about isaac's
suicide letter
he had an affair with sarah for six
months before her death
he killed himself because he couldn't
lie to julia anymore
a few days later julia goes through a
surgery she has to live with the bandage
around her eyes for a week
only after that will we know if the
surgery has been successful
during this time she will stay under
supervision in her twins house
the hospital provides julia with a
caretaker named ivan
to help her around the house he gives
her a device to hang around her neck so
that she can call him any time she wants
that night julia gets a nightmare about
isaac and sarah trying to get her
bandage off
she wakes up terrified then she hears
footsteps from outside
she calls ivan through the device he
tells her to get out of the house
she escapes just then someone takes the
key crespillo had given her
the police come in the following day but
they do not find any evidence of
invasion
ivan lovingly changes julia's bandage
for the next few days
he takes great care of her changing her
bandages
cooking for her listening to music with
her and whatnot
but throughout all those times we never
get to see ivan's face
on the third day julia asks him to stay
for drinks
they have a conversation about isaac
after which she kisses him
that night julia is woken up by a
nightmare as she reaches for her wedding
ring on the side table
we see a set of hospital tools similar
to one from the night of sarah's death
someone from behind her tries to inject
her with a drug this wakes her up
and she finally touches the man
terrified
she runs out of the house to her
neighbor bloss goes home
his daughter leah is home too he lets
her inside but starts to harass julia
shortly she is surprised to find sarah's
key in his house she takes it with her
she escapes from his house and hides in
a corner calling ivan for help
finally ivan comes to save her she is
too scared to go into her own house
so he takes her to his there she tells
him that she found sarah's key at mr
blasco's home
she suspects that blasco is the
invisible man
ivan leaves for some time when leah
approaches julia
she has followed them here and snuck
into the house through the windows
leah tells julia that she was the one
who stole the key from her house and
that she knows who killed sarah and
isaac
it is the invisible man ivan himself
leah reveals that she used to be close
to sarah and knows a lot about the
invisible man
julia doesn't believe it but leah
insists that the key unlocks one of the
locks in ivan's house
ivan has been drugging julia to make her
go blind as he did with sarah
leah tells julia to go to the bathroom
and stay there until leah finds a way to
escape
when ivan comes back she asks him to
take her to the bathroom
she then opens her bandage four days
before the schedule
luckily the operation is successful and
she is happy to have gained her vision
back
she quickly goes outside and enters one
of the rooms
she is shocked to see many pictures of
sarah and herself on the wall
julia leaves the room to look for leah
but sees her body stabbed to the wall
ivan had killed her too terrified she
sits down in the corner crying
just then ivan comes into the room we
see his face for the first time
it is splattered with leah's blood julia
poses as though the surgery was
unsuccessful
and pretends that she is still blind
ivan expresses his love for her
now she is in the kitchen with him she
sees him drugging her cup of tea
julia then replaces her cup of tea with
his ivan doesn't notice but he gets
suspicious
he takes her to the freezer and asks her
to open it inside it
is the dead body of real ivan julia
gasps
giving away that she can actually see
the imposter ivan calls her a liar
he then takes her to sarah's house but
julia manages to run away from him into
soledad's house
there she asks her to call the police
but ivan comes in before she can
he calls soledad mom revealing that he
is actually her son
angel julia pleads with soledad to call
the police but angel convinces her that
he is not a killer
then soledad hits julia on her head with
a phone
angel realizes that his mother can see
soledad reminds him he will be nothing
without her
this agitates on hell so he chokes her
he wants her to go back to being blind
again
he pokes her eyes with a needle when
julia wakes up
she is in the basement of sarah's house
angel sits in front of her
he has packed all her clothes and plans
to take her away to live with him
as he starts to kiss her julia takes a
knife and stabs him on his legs
she quickly runs out of the basement and
locks him there
but she can't get out of the house she
calls the police
just as angel breaks the door julia cuts
off all the lights in the house
it is pitch dark angel uses his camera
flash to look for julia
and finds her as he tries to stab her
the police come in
but they too cannot see anyone in the
dark room julia takes one of the
torchlights from them
and shines it to angel in the corner the
shadow finally comes to light
angel cannot handle being looked at by
so many people so he slits his throat
killing himself
cut to a few weeks later julia is at the
hospital
she finds that the damage to her new
eyes is irreversible as she had been
continuously injected by her fake
caretaker
using her last few hours of vision julia
says goodbye to isaac's corpse
it is revealed that he was the one who
donated her with his eyes
the movie ends as the camera zooms into
julia's eye
now for the explanation sarah and julia
both have a condition called
degenerative vision
this causes them to lose their vision
progressively eventually going blind
sarah loses her vision before julia
angel has a fascination for blind girls
he calls himself an invisible man this
is a metaphor for him trying to say that
he has no friends or family
no one notices him when he's around
because he's not worth noticing
over time angel has developed the
ability to be stealthy
and stop victims efficiently he took
care of his mother soledad for 10 years
thinking she was blind
soledad was the only person who he
talked to this
filled on hell with resentment towards
everyone who did not notice or care for
him
however he fell in love with sarah and
then julia
according to him only blind girls could
feel his presence
sarah tells her other blind friends at a
center for the blind that she's been
dating someone
this person is on hell once she has her
eyes operated
she goes with angel to a hotel in bella
vista for a week
at this point she has her eyes bandaged
we are not told what circumstances she
meets with angel perhaps he was posing
as her caretaker
and his empathy was winning sarah over
angel doesn't want sarah getting her
eyesight back
he ensures that he sneaks up on sarah in
the nights and injects her eyes with
chemicals that destroy the optic nerve
the doctor declares that the operation
has failed sarah gets to know that
someone is following her
she could feel his presence and resented
him so he killed her
when julia came looking for sarah angel
saw it as another opportunity at love
but julia had her husband always by her
side
hence angel killed him as well however
the neighbor girl
leah helped julia find out about angel's
real intentions before he could blind
julia fully
at the end finally julia makes him
visible to everyone
he had always been a lonely man so when
the police officers had their eyes on
him
he could not handle it killing himself
at the end that's my explanation for the
movie julia's eyes subscribe for more
videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching